monsieur bonjour Merci de votre présence
à cette audition deant notre commission
d'enquête sur le l'impact d'une
narcotrafic en France et les mesures à
prendre pour irmédier je vais commencer
par l'obligation formelle de prestation
de serment je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serit passive des peines prévu
aux articles 434-13
434-14 et 434- 155 du code pénal et je
vais donc vous inviter chacune et chacun
d'entre vous à prêter serement de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité à
lever la main droite et à dire je le
jure fait vous pouvez faire
collectivement ça ne ça n'enlèvera rien
à la sincérité de la Merci
euh
on on convoque et on procède
systématiquement de la même façon un
petit propos liiminaire pour que vous
nous éclairiez un peu sur ce qui
détermine
votre avis et la contribution que vous
pouvez apporter devant cette commission
puis ensuite on on se prête à à
l'échange question réponse ça vous va et
ben la parole est à vous dans l'ordre
qui vous convient on vous laisse vous
organiser voilà alors peut-être petit
propos liminire en effet pour pour me
présenter présenter le le ressort de
l'un donc je suis procureur de la de la
République à à bourcambress depuis le 23
juin 2023 donc quelques mois seulement
avec un un recul sur ce ressort donc que
je suis en train de de découvrir mais
néanmoins j'ai été procureur à à Macon
de 2011 à 2018 et donc frontalière de ce
ressort donc ça me permettait également
d'avoir une connaissance un peu
indirecte un un ressort de 680000
habitants environ
7562 km² ce qui me permet de dire qu'en
effet nous avons des particularismes
très différents avec des des zones
géographiques qui se répartissent peu
auou prou entre les quatre compagnies de
gendarme puisque nous avons un secteur
gendarmerie à
bourcambress une compagnie à trévous qui
va être plutôt frontalière de Lyon avec
un axe qu'on appelle la Côtière qui
géographiquement va va amener
effectivement des trafics qui viennent
de la région lyonnaise et avec un axe
autoroutier qui nous amène effectivement
une porosité sur sur ce secteur de
Trévou euh le secteur de Belet plutôt
limitrophe de de la Haute Savoie avec
euh euh pour le coup une compagnie à
Belet euh plus rurale et plus
montagnarde mais néanmoins la proximité
de Chamberry et puis l'iser pas très
loin et puis le paysjx euh qui présente
le le particularisme de d'être
totalement frontalier de Genève euh
puisque là on est à quelques ans
cabulure de de Genève et avec
effectivement une coopération euh à
cultiver avec les autorités suisses en
secteur police euh deux commissariats
l'un basé à bourcambrest l'autre autre à
oyona c'est la direction départementale
de la de la police de de lin et avec la
particularité mais j'y reviendrai de
quatre OPG spécialisés en stupéfiant
uniquement à
bourcambrress avec effectivement des
effectifs àoyona inexistant sur la
spécialisation stupéfiant donc donc
exclusivement des des OPG basé à
bourcambrress 47000 affaires pénales
reçues euh environ 4000 affaires
poursuivables
et j'y reviendrai là aussi je pense que
dans notre échange on approfondira un
petit peu les les chiffres en matière de
stupéfiant globalement une grande masse
d'usage de stupéfiant avec une baisse
significative sur les deux dernières
années lié notamment évidemment à la à
l'amand forfaitaire d'ellectuelle mais
aussi peut-être à des politiques un
petit peu différentes sur sur le terrain
puisqu'on est passé de 800 affaires de
stupéfiants avec une assez forte
proportion de mineurs à aujourd'hui un
peu plus de 200 250 affaires qui sont
soumises au parquet là je parle de
l'usage pur et donc de
l'axe traitement des affaires de de
stupéfiant sous l'axe plutôt usager sous
l'axe addiction qui est un axe
particulier avec pour le parquet quand
même de deux
observations l'absence de médecin relais
donc des grandes difficultés de prise en
charge sur le plan sanitaire puisque le
traitement des des addictions souffre de
délais importants des associations
matière de lutte contre les addictions
en nombre insuffisant et des difficultés
de prise en charge et puis effectivement
une part de mineur qui tend aujourd'hui
à se réduire encore dans le traitement
des stupéfiants sur cet axe très très
usagé du fait de l'audition libre et du
fait de la réforme des mineurs alors qui
nous a impacté dans dans le sens où nous
avons des des avocats euh qui ont des
permanences sectorisées donc quatre
quatre ressorts quatre arrondissement
différents qui se déplace assez peu et
donc on regroupe les auditions de
mineurs dans les brigades de gendarmerie
une journée par mois avec des grandes
difficultés de disponibilité des uns et
des autres he puisque territoire très
vaste disponibilité des avocat lié à à
la à la difficulté ben de dédier des
permanences aux affaires de mineurs et
donc quasiment plus d'auditions libres
euh avec un stock qui se crée dans les
services de de police et de gendarmerie
et notamment si je le cite ici en
matière d'usage puisque euh c'est
c'était une de mes interrogations en
arrivant c'esttait dire je je suis
étonnée de la de la chute drastique des
affaires en en nombre de mineurs et de
fait il y avait une forte proportion
d'usagers de stupéfiant avec des
orientations souvent en alternative euh
sur la prise en charge sanitaire donc ça
ça n'existe quasiment plus euh il y a
une réflexion à l'œuvre sur la façon de
traiter
aujourd'hui c'est ces procédures et puis
y a un stock de 400 procédures non
traité en matière de mineur du fait
encore une fois de C de ces
problématiques donc ça c'est les les
deux impacts ensuite pour la réponse
pénale et et pour ne ne pas abuser du du
temps de mon collègue mais ensuite on
reviendra dans le
détail des axes de transit donc on a là
je parle du trafi cette fois donc des
faits transport détension obsession on a
des axes autoroutiers assez importants
beaucoup d'affaires de comparitiontion
immédiate lorsque c'est du simple
transit avec toujours la même difficulté
de la preuve et de fait de remonter les
réseaux puisque ce sont souvent des
affaires traitées un peu en en
pardonnez-moi du terme mais en one shot
sur le transporteur et de fait sur la
saisie du produit mais mais assez peu
sur finalement les réseaux puisqu'on a
on a peu d'éléments à
exploiter des affaires qui partent alors
à contrario à l'instruction
dans le cadre et ma collègue sera là
aujourd'hui pour vous illustrer quelques
dossiers un peu significatifs part à
l'instruction sur des dossiers où là on
remonte des filières c'est souvent des
filières en lien avec lon c'est
étonnamment et et quand je dis
étonnamment c'est en tout cas encore à
mon stade l'étonnement de ma part de
constater que nous n'avons pas de
filière en tout cas identifié mise à
jour avec l'axe je ne vois donc pas de
demande d'entraide pour le moment dans
ce sens-là alors que de fait les trafics
existent mais il n'y a pas d'affaires
qui se sont qui se sont porté sur ce cet
axe du paysjx et de de Genève donc pas
de demande d'entraî en cours en revanche
pas mal d'affaires avec Lyon et avec des
fournisseurs lyonnais ou en tout cas en
provenance de de cette filière lyonnaise
12 commissions rogatoires en stock ça
veut dire 12 affaires au total et elles
ont une moyenne d'âge entre euh on va
dire 18 mois et 3 ans donc sur les trois
dernières années on a un stock de 12
affaires CIN affaires d'instruction par
an ce qui est assez faible en nombre
mais représente quand même la majorité
des mises en examen et des détenus
puisque nous avons 39 mises en examen en
matière de stupéfiant donc des dossiers
avec de nombreux mises en examen 15
détenus à l'heure actuelle et parfois
des ramification avec la JIRS de Lyon
qui nous permett de dire
qu'effectivement le haut du panier se
situe sur la région lyonnaise évidemment
au-delà hein puisque c'est c'est des
réseaux d'approvisionnement en cannabis
principalement depuis l'Espagne et que
nous avons un peu des bases arrières
récemment une affaire qui a débouché sur
bourcambrress même avec un fournisseur
local très établi dans la place et qui
se ravitaillait sur la la zone lyonnaise
euh donc ça c'est un peu la
configuration réponse pénale donc
finalement peu d'affaires qui
aboutissent à
l'instruction les affaires de de de
trafic du tout vant qui vont souvent en
comparition immédiate ou en comparition
en délai rapproché puis des petites
affaires de point de Deal locaux donc là
on arrive vraiment au niveau je dirais
du du du terrain et du local avec pour
le coup là des réponses assez
diversifiées qui vont aller depuis la
copj devant le tribunal à des réponses
effectivement comme je vous l'indiquais
au niveau des usagers qui vont être des
alternatives aux poursuites alors avec
un un petit focus et et je vous ai
envoyé le le panorama géographique sur
les les points deal répertoriés qui sont
les points deal répertoriés sur lesquels
ont travaillé les services de police
locaux alors il y en avait 19 mais ce
qui représente très peu par rapport à la
réalité du terrain c'est-à-dire les 19
identifiés sont ceux sur lesquels les
services se sont se sont focalisés et et
ont travaillé au cours des deux
dernières années bien évidemment il y en
a il y en a beaucoup plus la difficulté
est encore une fois de mettre des des
effectifs dédiés sur ces objectifs euh
un Ltd donc groupe local de traitement
de la délinquence que nous envisageons
et sur lequel nous allons commencer à
travailler avec Madame perti carot dans
le secteur de Trévou donc toute cette
zone de la Côtière donc Lyon Trévou à la
demande de la gendarmerie qui identifie
des des quartiers et des des zones très
impactées par le trafic de stupéfiants
de façon à pouvoir donner des des
réponses plus rapide plus coercitive et
puis je dirais très sect très sectorisé
on est vraiment sur la
territorialisation de l'action publique
avec des des réponses qui soient au plus
proche du du terrain et puis je finirai
simplement c'est c'est vraiment un
panorama général mais par dire que à mon
sens le point essentiel sur ma première
approche de de ce territoire c'est
vraiment la configuration ressources
humaines en terme de service de police
et de gendarmerie nous avons donc quatre
compagnies de gendarmerie quatre
brigades de recherche
spécialisé dans le judiciaire qui qui au
total des effectifs constituent une
trentaine d'OPJ qui ne sont pas
spécialisés en matière de stupéfiant
donc 30 sur 400 OPJ au niveau du
territoire au niveau des brigades 30
spécialisés en judiciaire au niveau des
brigades de recherche aucun nétant
véritablement spécialisé en groupe stup
le la spécialisation stupéfiante
n'existe pas elle existe un peu plus au
niveau de la section de recherche de
valsorone qui est une antenne de la
section de recherche du du 69 de de Lyon
et qui a été créée l'année dernière donc
elle est elle est toute récente cette
antenne elle est située sur le paysjx
avec un intérêt à la fois frontalier
enreide pénale
internationale une vision clairement
économique et financière aussi parce que
c'est un autre axe valserone oui à côé
elle est à valseron la la la la section
de recherche l'antenne de la SR de Lyon
à la gendarmerie de valseron voilà et
elle est elle est existante depuis
quelques mois puisqu'elle a moins d'une
année d'existance donc elle n'a pas
encore produit de dossier de stupéfiant
ad hoc mais en terme d'initiative je
pense qu'elle va être amenée précisément
à à trouver l'information que nous
n'avons pas sur cette cette partie de la
frontière
payjx une ialité
outi
par oui alors
est elle est
voation sa vocation est à la fois
spécialisé en matière économique et
financière une approche blanchiment et
une approche stupéfiante qu'elle devrait
promouvoir sur ce secteur
du où jusqu'à présent n av rien que la
BR de que la BR de qui a actu
donc 30 30 OPG non spécialisés et 7 se
pour la section de recherche de
Val au niveau du commissariat de
bourcambress je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
une équipe stupéfiant de 4
OPG pour l'ensemble de la ddpn donc de
la direction de la de la police
nationale ce qui est quand même très peu
vu vu la surface du du territoire zéro à
oyona qui apparaît là aussi assez
impacté puisque certaines affaires
notamment des affaires en cours sont
actuellement traitées par l'ofast mais
l'ofast version lyonnaise c'est-àdire
des dossiers pris en compte par laagirs
de Lyon ou par en tout cas la la PJ la
police judiciaire de Lyon sur sur la
partie enquête lyonnaise et puis
ramification à oyona mais aucune affaire
qui dans l'autre sens part du terrain et
par doyona et donc la vraie
problématique en tout cas moi ce que
j'identifie c'est qu'on n' pas
d'initiative suffisante sur le terrain
du fait d'effectifs euh spécialisés euh
on va dire peu peu important et en tout
cas en difficulté puisque le
commissariat d'yona est en en difficulté
en l'absence de d'OPG euh donc ça c'est
un un petit peu le le constat euh les
axes de travail euh la possibilité de
travailler avec le le GIR euh qui euh
fait une offre de service et que nous
avons rencontré récemment pour pouvoir
mobiliser euh des effectifs en appu appu
des unités locales et en appuie à la
fois sur le patrimonial sur l'axe
économique et financier et puis en
appuie effectif moyen interpellation et
écoute téléphonique axe d'enquête au
soutien des équipes locales tant de la
gendarmerie que de la police d'ailleurs
puisqu'on est là sur sur de l'Inter
direirectionnel donc il y a pas de
l'interministériel il y a pas de
difficulté et puis une absence d'antenne
de la police judiciaire dans l'un et
c'était une de vos questions je crois la
la coordination de l'auface consiste en
une cross qui se situe dans le
69 pas de réunion de la Cross 01 ces
dernières années en tout cas dans les
archives que j'ai pu trouver dans
l'historique qu'on m'en adressé pas de
réunion dans dans le 01 donc là aussi je
pense qu'il faut remobiliser la Cross 69
au profit de l'un puisque nous dépendons
certes de la de la PJ de Lyon mais
faut-il effectivement qu'il y a une
émanation au niveau du du territoire
dans l'un en terme de partage
d'information en terme de formation des
OPJ et puis et puis en terme
d'initiative j'y reviens parce que qui
dit affaire de stupéfiant dit qu'il faut
aussi bah faire remonter l'information
et et et en tout cas au départ définir
les objectifs donc je crois que le le
constat de dire que nous avons
finalement une proportion d'affaires
assez réduite même si on a eu et et et
Madame perticaro pourra le compléter des
affaires assez significatives et
intéressantes donc la matière y est
principalement je l'ai je l'ai pas dit
tout à l'heure mais principalement des
affaires sur 90 % c'est du cannabis sous
toutes ses formes de la résine et
évidemment de l'herbe également très peu
d'affaires de de d'héroïne et de cocaïne
un petit peu de cocaïne sur bour
cambrress et sur les zones plutôt
urbaines peu de drogue de synthèse
quasiment pas dans dans les saisis et
puis un gros centre pénitentiaire de 700
détenus euh qui là aussi nous amène
chaque année de façon constante sur les
trois dernières années à à saisir du
stupéfiant 12 kg c'est un peu la moyenne
annuelle et c'est régulier et ça baisse
pas malgré tous les contrôles et malgré
toutes les les les stratégies mises en
place c'est globalement chaque année la
la le le même quantum de de saisie en
maison d'arrêt avec des des vigilances
effectivement sur les modes de d'entrée
du stupéfiant donc pour nous aussi un
point d'attention et un et un point de
politique pénale avec des réponses
stématiqu qui sont donné en matière de
de de comparition immédiate notamment
quand ce sont des quantités
significatives voilà voilà un petit peu
le panorama général je pense que si vous
le souhaitez on reviendra à des à des
points plus
détaillés merci beaucoupame le procureur
peut-être que on passe la parole à
Monsieur le Procureur de la République
du parquet de Bayon bourer et puis
ensuite on ouvrira
oui monsieur le Président je vous faire
une une présentation succinte complément
de ce qu'a pu dire ma collègue parce
qu'il y a aussi des thématiques qui
malheureusement sont très communes à
l'ensemble du territoire national sur
les singularités du tribunal judiciaire
de Bayonne donc qui qui recouvre ce
qu'on appelle le Pays Basque hein en
tout cas ce que les Basques appellent le
Pays-Basque puisqu'il y a une
agglomération du Paysbasque qui regroupe
toutes les communes de ce territoire les
singularité elles sont elles sont
connues mais évidemment elles tiennent
beaucoup à à sa dimension frontalière et
au fait
que c'est un des axes un des grands axes
de pénétration du cannabis en France les
deux principaux à mon avis hein que sont
Biriatou dans le Pays Basque et puis les
pyrinées orientales évidemment puisque
nous saisissons environ alors c'est une
moyenne mais environ 10 tonnes de
cannabis par an grosso modo avec une
particularité c'est l'existence du
phéage de Biriatou qui centre 95 % des
vecteurs routiers sur 5 % du territoire
frontalier point où se trouve situés de
nombreux servicees de police et pas
seulement
puisque sont présents l'administration
des douanes la direction interrégionale
des douanes se trouve à Bayonne les
douanes la police de l'air et des
frontières puisque la direction
interdépartementale alors maintenant
çappelle la sipaf mais se trouve
également à Bayonne donc la police de
les frontières la gend gendarmerie la
police et côté espagnol la Guardia
civile et la police basque qui a des
pouvoirs très importants he qui sont qui
sont pas du tout comparables à nos
polices municipales puisque sur le
territoire basque l'ertsenza a même
davantage de pouvoir que n'en a la
Guardia civile en réalité et donc
pourquoi je dis ça c'est que évidemment
cette archiprésence des services de
l'état des services policiers
franco-espagnols a induit des modes
d'organisation et des spécialisations et
des équipes qui sont finalement
spécialisées dans la traversée de la
frontière soit à Biriatou soit dans
l'école puisqu'il y a aussi de la drogue
qui passe par des zones plus rurales et
et et par
l'école avec des grosses capacités pour
vous donner un exemple en 2023 un
narcotrafiquant d'ampleur de cannabis a
été interpellé il expliquait que il
budgetait mensuellement 1 million
d'euros pour récupérer du cannabis dans
le sud de l'Espagne organiser ses
équipes les véhicules les convois et
cetera qu'il revendait 2,3 million
d'euros en région parisienne tous les
mois voilà ça donne une idée d'une part
de l'ampleur du trafic et d'autre part
des marges qui sont réalisées par ces
trafiquants donc euh les c'est les deux
spécificités du ressort je dirais c'est
celle-là c'est une part très importante
du transit international de cannabis
dans le sens
Sud-Nord de la cocaïne dans une moindre
mesure mais dans le sens inverse nord-
sudud en descendance vers l'Espagne vers
le
Portugal une délinquence organisée
associé à cela qui peut-être soit une
délinquence de transit pour lesquels
nous utilisons beaucoup les comparitions
immédiates ou des dénonciations officiel
aux autorités espagnoles mais je pense
qu'on y reviendra par rapport à votre
questionnaire et des trafics locaux plus
ruraux qui ont aussi leur spécificité
c'est-à-dire que ces trafics qui sont
nombreux n'ont pas besoin de s'appuyer
je dirais en approvisionnement sur des
grandes agglomérations Toulouse Bordeaux
ou même Bayonne mais vont
s'approvisionner directement en Espagne
sur des quantités à chaque fois
relativement réduites ce qui rend
difficile de de caractériser l'ampleur
du trafic parce qu'en réalité ils vont
se fournir autant qu'ils le veulent
aussi souvent qu'ils le veulent en
Espagne et donc il rapporte la
marchandise directement d'Espagne pour
organiser des euh des des petits trafics
ou des trafics locaux voilà donc pour
moi ce sont sans peut-être rentrer pour
le moment davantage dans le détail les
deux singularités du territoire
avec cette chance d'une certaine manière
de bénéficier sur ce ressort pour le
cout de service de police spécialisé
important alors l'administration des
douises n'est pas un service de police
mais elle est euh à l'origine d'une très
grosse partie des saisies qui sont
réalisées le tout étant d'être en
capacité pour les services d'enquête de
valoriser ces mises à disposition brute
de de de produits saisis la présence
d'un service interdépartemental de
police judiciaire à Bayonne d'une
antenne ofaste à Bayonne et donc malgré
tout d'un d'un spectre de moyens pour
lutter contre la délinquence organisée
important s'agissant de la lutte contre
le trafic local là c'est autre chose et
et je rejoindrai les les les les les
propos de ma collègue on a des services
qui sont très clairement
sous-dimensionnés très clairement
sousdimensionnés c'est-à-dire qu' un
groupe stup de sécurité publique alors
dans le cadre de la réorganisation de la
police nationale ce groupe stupéfiant il
y a trois commissariats sur le
Pays-Basque Bayon Biaritz Saint-Jean
delus mais il y a un groupe stupéfiant
qui était
districal et qui désormais depuis
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme de la
police nationale est rattaché au service
organiquement et fonctionnellement au
service interdépartemental de la police
judiciaire sipj hein et qui vient
constituer une division de la
criminalité territoriale division c'est
un grand mot parce que c'est
actuellement six enquêteurs voilà six
enquêteurs en zone gendarmerie ben c'est
la Brigade de Recherche et la la section
de recherche qui vont travailler sur les
sur les réseaux de trafic de stupéfiants
mais avec des effectifs qui sont il faut
bien l'admettre très limité j'ai
comptabilisé le nombre d'affaires de
trafic de stupéfiants démelés en zone
rurale par les services de gendarmerie
sur l'année
2023 il y en a
euh c'est pas énormein alors
évidemmentin l'offaste est chef de fil
traite les plus gros dossier mais une
douzaine de trafic démelé sur une année
en zone rurale si vous voulez en soit on
pourrait en faire le double on pourrait
en faire le triple on pouroudrait en
faire le quadruple hein tout ça est une
question de moyen dédié et et et de ce
qu'on veut faire voilà sur ce propos
liminaire merci Monsieur le Procureur
ben je vais passer la main à notre
rapporteur je sais pas s'il connaî aussi
bien Bayon que pour
cambrress oui bien
SRC la
la
discussion vous avez
constaté dans fonction dans V anciennes
fonctions le le
développement zres sur
lesquell' Av aucune
suspicion de trafic et aujourd'hui c'est
l'ensemble du territoire
c'est un
constors
d' ouis
prenez-le c'est un constat qui est très
largement partagé alors tout d'abord ça
tient une première chose c'est que la
consommation de stupéfiants n'est pas
quelque chose qui est réservé aux
agglomérations hein et qu'on retrouve de
la consommation de cannabis ou de
cocaïne parce qu'on a aussi des trafic
locau de cocaïne en zone rurale hein qui
touche énormément de monde il y a
certaines professions aussi qui sont
très touchées alors je sais pas si on
abordera la question ultérieurement mais
bon par exemple les marins pêcheurs sur
la cocaïne c'est quelque chose de qui
est connu mais c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas nutre notamment sur leur
participation éventuelle à l'entrée sur
le territoire national de cocaïne
d'ailleurs sur lequel on est
complètement aveugle euh mais évidemment
la consommation elle est
démocratiquement répartie sur l'ensemble
du territoire et compris dans les zones
rurales donc ça c'est une réalité euh
ensuite
euh s'agissant du Pays-Basque il est
certain que la dimension frontalière ce
que je disais tout à l'heure dans mon
propos liminaire favorise
l'autoalimentation de ces trafics locaux
sans avoir besoin de passer par des
fournisseurs qui se trouveraient dans
des grandes villes voilà ça c'est c'est
évidemment un facteur extrêmement
facilitant et puis il y a un espèce de
de phénomène je dirais de de capillarité
qu'on constate qui fait que pour moi
d'ailleurs la lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiant dire quand on parle de lutte
contre la délinquence
organisée c'est la priorité des
priorités ce devrait être la priorité
des priorités encore faut-il savoir
comment on peut être efficace mais il y
a cette espèce de mécanisme de
capillarité qu'on voit bien on le on
prend la la la problématique par exemple
des des règlements de compte ou des des
narcomicides comme les a appelé la
procureur de Marseille qui est une bonne
appellation je pense on voit bien que
cette pratique là était réservée à un
certain nombre de cité Marseille où j'ai
exercé où j'ai connu cela Toulouse
quelques villes et puis que cette espèce
de culture de
contreculture c'est c'est diffusé dans
des
agglomérations moins grande et à travers
des menaces des enlèvements des
tentatives des violences puis maintenant
des homicide et tout ça a S voilà et on
a en zone rurale on a des exemples de
dossiers où il y a eu des tirs d'armes à
feu alors pas de meurtrre mais des tirs
d'armes à feu des intimidations toute
cette culture finalement qui était celle
qu'on connaissait dans des grandes
agglomération elle s'est petit à petit
répandu sur ces territoires et puis
l'avantage des zones rurales c'est aussi
que on y est
tranquille le maillage de la gendarmerie
nationale est certes un maillage
intéressant et une source de
renseignement mais pour
autant pour autant c'est pas une brigade
territoriale qui va être en capacité de
démanteler un réseau de stupéfiant
conséquent donc c'est aussi sont aussi
des zones de repli qui à mon avis sont
intéressantes pour des trafiquants
voilà
alors là aussi je je rejoins tout à fait
les les propos de mon mon collègue et
sans concertation je dirais que on fait
les mêmes constats moi je fais le
constat aussi de d'axes de circulation
qui sont un un vecteur finalement de de
porosité et de rapprochement et de
facilitation puisque aujourd'hui c'est
peut dire qu'on est dans une société où
on circule beaucoup mais aussi les pôles
d'attraction sont des pôles d'attraction
qui vont rayonner beaucoup plus loin
chez nous dans l'un on a deux pôles
d'attraction majeur que sont la région
lyonnaise et la région de Genève et bien
évidemment nos axes de circulation nos
autoroute et nos axes de circulation
facilit là aussi l'installation et le
trafic sur des zones limitrophes
lorsqu'on est dans le pays Jack on est à
à 20 minutes de la de de la frontière
Suisse on est on est en Suisse en
quelques encablures les délinquant le
savent et alors la frontière c'est
encore une autre problématique euh
au-delà de la zone rurale savent aussi
parfois qu'en franchissant la frontière
ça va démultiplier les difficultés en
terme d'enquête et en terme de bah de de
de répression et donc vont jouer et on
l'a bien connu sur ces zones
frontalières moi je l'ai connu ailleurs
en Alsace avec la proximité de bal et
les réseaux albanais qui étaient situés
de part et d'autres de la frontière très
volontairement pour se jouer de de cette
frontière en terme d'abris et c'est la
même chose pour les zones rurales on
voit effectivement des délinquants et
qui parfois nous le disent en disant
benah je suis allé mettre un petit peu
plus au vert parce que c'était plus
facile effectivement dans le village où
vous êtes anonyme plutôt que identifi
avec des services de police peut-être
effectivement plus plus plus présents
sur le territoire en matière de
stupéfiant il y a donc il y a cette
notion de tranquillité et en même temps
cette notion bah de facilité finalement
de circulation avec aussi la la notion
un petit peu de base arrière puisque on
a aussi ce phénomène aujourd'hui bah de
lieu d'approvisionnement et stockage que
ce soit d'ailleurs sur la périphérie de
grande ville pas forcément toujours dans
la grande ville mais je pense à à
vénicieux pour avoir exercé en région
lyonnaise pour le coup de voir queon est
là sur des zones de distribution et
qu'on va véritablement après avoir des
relais dans des villes moyennes ça a été
le cas à bourcambrress où on a démelé
plusieurs affaires bah finalement de
base arrière de trafiquants lyonnais qui
tout simplement allit ravitailler euh
une partie du du secteur et qui tout
simplement se comporte comme des
distributeurs avec avec des stratégies
qui sont des stratégies géographiques de
pouvoir ravitailler au plus près du
terrain donc on se rapproche de la
clientèle et comme le disait mon
collègue la clientèle il y en a un peu
partout et en matière de cabis c'est une
banalisation de la consommation donc
effectivement des des particularités qui
font qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que bah c'est c'est pour eux de partout
mais avec toujours quand même des pôles
d'attraction quand vous êtes à proximité
de de métropole tel Genève et et Lyon
évidemment de de trafic qui sont des
trafics extrêmement structurés en amont
ce sont les mêmes qu'on a simplement sur
des niveaux dégradés très bien
mer par pardon
madame juste une une précision sur en
fait je crois qu'il y a aussi une une
banalisation de de l'usage de stupéfiant
j'entends par là que à travers les
réseaux sociaux notamment les réseaux
cryptés en fait il est téégram snapchat
et cetera il est extrêmement facile
aujourd'hui pour des usagers de
commander notamment de la cocaïne he
c'est c'est euh une une drogue qui est
vraiment très répandue dans au Pays-Bas
puisque l'argent les les les les
habitants ont plus d'argent et tout
simplement il vous suffit de d'être
abonné à un compte télégram vous pouvez
passer commande on vient vous livrer
chez vous et il y a véritablement ce ce
cette sensation de de d'être en dehors
de la loi et de ne de ne rien risquer et
c'est un vrai problème aujourd'hui je
pense et c'est
aussi une vision très importante de de
de la délinquence autour de du trafic de
suéfiant c'est qu'il y a une véritable
impunité des délinquants par rapport à
cela parce que les services d'enquête
aujourd'hui ne sont pas en capacité de
d'infiltrer ou ou de pénétrer ce réseau
de telgram parce que une fois que vous
avez euh vous je peux vous montrer des
exemples on on a ce fil de discussion
mais c'est impossible de remonter au
numéro de téléphone parce que euh voilà
les les applications sont faites de
telle manière qu'on ne peut pas savoir
qui est derrière tout cela et donc euh
peut se dérouler véritablement un un
commerce de véritables start-up où il y
a des cartes de fidélité des
promos des des des prix de vente en gros
on vous informe de l'arrivée du produit
de la qualité du produit et tout ceci
permet en fait de développer
véritablement le trafic et au final les
techniques traditionnelles d'enquête que
sont la géolocalisation les écoutes
téléphoniques les surveillances
physiques elles permettent pas d'être
efficaces ou alors elles demandent
beaucoup de temps pour réussir à
démanteler ce réseau et au final on
n'arrive pas non plus à percevoir toute
l'Ance de ce réseau qui est sous-terrain
invisible et je crois en tout cas moi
j'ai interrogé les services de de police
et de gendarmerie pour savoir si par le
biais de l'article 7
706-32 ce qu'on appelle les coûts
d'achat est-ce qu'on pourrait s'en
provoquer à l'infraction mais se faire
passer pour je simplifie hein se faire
passer pour un acheteur et infiltrer ce
ce réseau et c'est très difficile pour
les serv d'enquête parce que il y a des
problèmes de de compéten techniques il a
une une formation spécialisée qui est
requise ce qui n'est pas le cas des des
enquêteurs à Bayonne une technicité pour
acquérir du matériel permettant
éventuellement d'infiltrer et en l'état
aucun service d'enquête n'est en
capacité d'enquêter sur cette nouvelle
voie de communication qui me paraître
essentiel et qui laisse à mon sens un
sentiment d'impunité pour ces
trafiquants qui peuvent en fait
développer leur entreprise comme comme
on leur semble à à tous les niveaux de
la société très explicite ce que vous ce
que vous dites pardon et c'est qu'il y a
un problème de cryptage si on pénétrait
mieux ces communications on prendrait à
quelque chose et euh un système
d'infiltration qui est à améliorer sur
le système d'infiltration quelles sont
les suggestions quels sont les points
faibles que vous avez
repérés alors c'est c'est très technique
je je suis pas spécialiste hein sur euh
est-ce qu'on pourrait je pense que il y
a eu des affaires skycc encrochat où les
services de police et gendarmerie ont
été cap capable de pénétrer des réseaux
des serveurs et on démantelit des des
réseaux incroyables je pense que
techniquement on serait en capacité
d'infiltrer mais voilà est-ce que est-ce
que c'est possible est-ce que voilà en
tout cas au niveau au niveau local les
services d'enquête ne sont pas doté de
de ces téléphones spécifiqu il faudrait
un téléphone de travail pour chaque
enquêteur permettant d'avoir un faux
compte et cetera ils ont pas ça
aujourd'hui ils ont pas les
habilitation technique leur permettant
de de faire cela et derrière tout cela
il faut quand même protéger aussi
enquêteurs qui ont peur de la
provocation l'infraction et cetera donc
en tout cas techniquement aujourd'hui en
terme de formation je pense que tant les
policiers que les gendarmes n'ont pas
n'ont pas les moyens de d'infiltrer ces
réseaux là c'est c'est une thématique
qui est relevée
notamment je pour l'avoir évoqué avec
lui avec le chef de l'antenne ofaste
c'estàd cette capacité à à à démel ce
qu'on appelle maintenant des points de
Deal numérique hein avoir la capacité
d'infiltration je pense que ça implique
un certain nombre de modifications
textuelles malgré Toutin pour permettre
ces infiltrations de manière plus facile
pour sécuriser les coups d'achat c'est
que le coût d'achat c'est toujours
quelque chose de de complexe il peut
être autorisé dans certaines conditions
mais il faut pas aller à la provocation
à l'infraction c'est quelque chose qui
est qui est complexe et donc je pense
que c'est c'est en tout cas c'est un
c'est un point extrêmement important
pour permettre aux enquêteurs d'accéder
au aux adresses IP et et à mettre en
place des véritables interceptions de
communication sur les messagesies
cryptés ça c'est si on rate ce virage là
euh aujourd'hui si vous voulez les
interceptions téléphoniques et les
messages et les SMS c'est c'est c'est
c'est le passé hein très
clairement il y a trafic
et il y a des flux financiers qui sont
particuliers parce que ce sont souvent
des espèces des petites coupures on paye
rarement avec sa carte bleue
et les sommes en jeu ce sont des
coupures de 10 20 50 € et régulièrement
quand on voit des saisis on voit des des
liases de de billets qui ont fait
l'objet saisi
et le le trafic total en France on
l'estime entre 4 et 6 milliards d'euros
à peu près au doigt mouillés enfin ce
sont des quantités de petites coupures
àissales comment vous expliquez qu'on
narrive pas mieux à les suivre ces
petites coupures
est-ce que on surveille mal le train de
vie d'un certain nombre de délinquants
est-ce que l'on surveille mal les
commerçants qui reçoivent ces sommes ou
celles et ceux qui les reçoivent est-ce
que le système bancaire permet
suffisamment de surveiller ses flux
financiers est-ce que vous avez un un
avis à nous donner sur ce
sujet alors tout d'abord évidemment euh
on saisit beaucoup d'argent nous sur le
ressort de Bayon euh en transit l'argent
du blanchiment hein dans un sens
Sud-Nord ou nord- sudud c'est de
l'argent qu'on poursuit sous la
qualification de blanchiment pour lequel
on ouvre des enquêtes conjointes entre
un service de police judiciaire et le
service le sejf le service des enquêtes
financièrees de de de de Bery euh et on
c'est de l'argent qui traverse la
frontière pour aller financer des achats
en Espagne alors soit c'est de l'argent
destiné à acheter de la matière
stupéfiante ça peut être le cas hein
soit c'est de l'argent qui est en cours
de blanchiment hein pour aller faire des
investissement à l'étranger par exemple
sur le ressort du Pays Basque moi qui
est un un secteur extrêmement attractif
sur le point de l'immobilier sur on a on
sort quasiment pas d'affaire de
blanchiment direct sur le territoire du
Pays-Basque en revanche des sommes qui
transitent on en saisit beaucoup et
parfois on se daisit au profit de la
geirs parce que ces sommes elles peuvent
être de 30000 à 200000 à 400000 € hein
et et et ça c'est évidemment tout ce
qu'on appelle le le le trafic des
collecteurs hein des gens qui sont en
charge d'évacuer et de blanchir l'argent
on sait qu'il y a notamment les réseaux
chinois qui sont très très fort et très
organisé sur ce plan-là donc ça c'est
une chose mais après par rapport à la
question que vous posez c'est une vraie
question c'est-à-dire de savoir si il
faut tracer le produit
stupéfiant ou s'il faut tracer les flux
financiers ça c'est une vraie
interrogation euh nous ne traçons ou
nous traçons très peu les les les les
produits financiers euh les Américains
le font je sais que la DEA euh est très
organisé euh sur le le le suivi des fux
financiers et il les laissent transiter
et ils les suivent et en fait ils
démentantellent une filière en suivant
l'argent bon ça en France on ne fait pas
très peu euh on essaie de trouver
l'argent de saisir de l'argent pour le
confisquer mais le démantèement d'un
réseau à partir finalement du suivi de
flux financiers et pas du produit c'est
quelque chose qui est peu développé en
France pourquoi je pense aussi parce que
c'est extrêmement lourd et compliqué et
technique donc c'est pas facile que
c'est pas dans la culture des groupes
spécialisés en matière de stupéfiant si
vous voulez dans dans dans Je je parle
en toute franchise mais euh il y a
euh dans dans dans les services
spécialisés de lut antistup au fast il y
a une notion de plaisir dans la manière
de travailler le le l'enquêteur le
policier qui fait du stup qu'est-ce
qu'il aime il aime trouver du produit se
faire une grosse saisie interpeller une
équipe un convoi armé si on lui
demandait de passer son temps à essayer
de tracer des flux financiers euh je
pense qu'il y aurait beaucoup moins de
vocation voilà
donc on n' pas cette culture là et on n
pas réussi en tout cas à les adjoindre
on pourrait envisager des groupes
communs où il y aurait à la fois des
enquêteurs spécialisés et certains qui
travailleraient exclusivement sur le
financier on n'a pas réussi à les
adjoindre les GIR
oui
GIR pardon oui
j'oublie faut
m'er
où vous avez à la gendarmerie de
valserone des gendarmes spécialisés sur
le suivi de ces flux financiers et là
vous pouvez nous donner quelques
indications et quelques précisions alors
alors pas encore parce que
malheureusement ça n'a pas encore porté
ses fruits c'est ce que je vous disait
hein l'implantation est toute récente
mais l'optique de travail est clairement
celle notamment avec également la la
cellule de lutte en matière financière
la celtif au niveau du groupement
l'optique est véritablement
travailler à la fois sur les flux
financiers mais de travailler aussi sur
le patrimonial clairement sur les
individus et les objectifs en partant de
la notion alors assez classique hein de
de train de vie mais faut-il partir du
financier pour faire le constat que le
train de vie ne correspond pas dans
l'effectivité des choses bah à à la
régularité des des revenus et donc
d'avoir une optique de travail inversé
de pas partir de la saisie et uniquement
du produit mais de partir d'une étude
par individus qui soit une étude
patrimoniale et financière donc ça c'est
l'idée de la section de recherche c'est
l'idée aussi d'gir enfin ça présidait
d'ailleurs la création des Gires hein
puisqu'on était là clairement sur
l'interministériel la présence conjointe
de l'administration fiscale alors qu'il
a pour le coup a des moyens
d'investigation souvent très efficaces
quand on met en commun la la la façon de
travailler des douan de l'administration
fiscale de la police et de la
gendarmerie et et moi mon idée aussi euh
c'est de repartir aussi d'enquête de
terrain avec l'appui euh du girire pour
pouvoir inverser encore une fois la
façon de les traiter parce que euh
partant du constat que l'initiative
locale il y en a assez peu et c'est ce
que je vousi expliquais de l'absence des
services spécialisés c'est-à-dire que
l'information pour qu'elle émerge euh il
faut qu'il y ait des services de de
terrain qui fassent du stupéfiant qui
fassent du de l'information et qui fasse
remonter des objectifs là l'optique de
travail pour être autre de partir euh
évidemment du du criblage d'un certain
nombre d'individus qui peuvent paraître
suspects notamment eu égard au train de
vie ou à des ou à des des masses
financières échangées à partir des
comptes bancaires et travailler d'abord
sur cet aspect-là pour ensuite
éventuellement mettre à jour des
activités illicites qu'elle soit dans le
cadre des stupéfiants ou d'autres
activités illicites puisque on n'a pas
forcément l'information au départ donc
le le GIR peut nous y aider puisque
c'est sa voocation première et les
sections de recherche à condition qu'on
soit effectivement sur un travail
financier en amont nous des saisis de de
vous parliez de petites coupure et des
saisies effectivement financières on en
a assez régulièrement dans dans dans les
dossiers qui peuvent l'illustrer mais on
n pas ni le point de départ ni le point
d'arrivée et je dirais au-delà du train
de vie et de ce qu'on peut établir
parfois d'un train de vie qui est en
léger décalage on n rien de très
significatif à apporter au tribunal sur
ce planlà donc il faut inverser vraiment
la l'optique d'enquête la
stratégieexemple
d'uneaire dans une zone rurale et un
réseau que l'on déstabilise ou que l'on
détruit parce qu'on a découvert des
espèces on a ça dans le département de
lin ou dans le départementon non non
vous savez enfin moi je suis je suis un
peu sceptique sur cette démarche là
parce que c'est ce qui a fondé le
lesgir et au départ et l'idée était même
plus précise on avait dit mais c'est pas
compliqué tous ces types qui roulent
avec des grosses voitures hein on va
travailler sur eux et on va démantel des
réseaux on en a démelé combien des
réseaux comme ça zéro euh ça je pense
pas que ça fonctionne voilà euh parce
qu'ils sont malins parce que les
voitures elles sont pas à leur nom parce
qu'ils sont pas propriétaires parce que
euh là où on fait les plus grosses
saisies d'argent ou de patrimoine je
parle pas de saisis d'argent euh qui
transit parce que là évidemment on
saisit des grosses d'argent mais les
saisies de patrimoine quand on essaie de
faire des saisies patrimoniales c'est
rarement dans les dossiers de stupéfiant
qu'on les fait rarement euh parce que
l'argent il est parce que les
investissements ils sont pas en France
en tout cas qu'on arrive pas à les
identifier hein il est rare qu'on
arrient à les identifier les gros
trafiquants de cannabis français ils
investissent pas en France hein ils
investissent on sait où ils investissent
ils investissent dans le sud de
l'Espagne ils investissent au Maroc ils
investissent mais ils investissent pas
en France donc cette démarche qui est
séduisante intellectuellement elle est
compliquée je sa pas qu'il faut pas la
suivre hein et qu'il faut pas tenter de
la suivre mais elle est elle est
compliqué
en terme d'efficacité de
résultats je
trouve alors le l'un des dossiers qu'on
souhaitait aujourd'hui vous présenter ne
parle pas de des flux financiers mais on
a néanmoins sur le train de vie des
éléments qui sont intéressants qui qui
ont été mis au jour puisque le gérant
principal qui a été qui a été identifié
dans le cadre de cette procédure au
niveau de son train de vie les
investigations mettent en évidence qu'on
a une personne qui dépense environ 8000
€
en terme de loisirs de façon mensuelle
2000 € pour le train de vie les dépenses
de la vie courante achat de nourriture
essence et et et vie du quotidien ce qui
fait quand même un budget c'est
conséquent tous les mois c'est une
personne qui pour autant n'a aucune
source de revenu ni ni salaire ni
prestation social et qui ne disposer
d'aucun compte bancaire donc là sur ce
dossier-l c'est un élément bien
évidemment qui n'a pas été le le point
de départ des investigations mais c'est
un élément qui est dans le cadre de
l'enquête de trafic de stupéfiants et
bien sûr très très intéressant et qu'on
a pu exploiter par la suite sur sur le
train de cette personne là pratiquement
et concrètement comment est-ce que vous
vous êtes aperçu qu'on dépensait 10000 €
dans des activités de loisir et et et
2000 € de de de nourriture et d'achat
courant comment qui est-ce qui vous a
informé comment civilier prix pour avoir
ces éléments de preuve
année à peu près avec des surveillances
qui ont été on est sur une enquête qui
qui a duré une année avec des
surveillances qui ont été importantes
avec des voyages à l'étranger donc des
vérifications qui se sont associées pour
les billets d'avion et les différents
lieux de destination on est sur des
estimations après qui sont qui sont
faites et également des interceptions
téléphoniques qui étaient nombreuses et
précise également sur sur des des
sorties au restaurant sur des achats et
des des marques de luxe qui était qui
était évoqué donc après c'est bien
évidemment des estimations qui sont
faites par les enquêteurs mais ça donne
quand même une idée assez intéressante
du train de vie de la personne entre les
différents voyages les lieux qu'
pouvaient fréquenter et euh et les
différents achats qu' pouvaient
effectuer et après des éléments qui se
sont confirmés avec des perquisition et
dans le casadre de ces perquisitions on
a retrouvé là encore un certain nombre
d'objets qui avaient été achetés qu'on
pouvait qu'on avait identifié tout au
long de la procédure avec le suivi de
durant l'enquête on sait qu' a des
moyens de blanchiment et c'est l'achat
et de fond de
commerce dans ce fond de commerce un
chiffre d'affaires qui est fictif
pendant quelques mois puis ensuite un
dépôt de bilan puis ensuite la revente
du fond est-ce que vous avez eu des
dossiers de cette nature et est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous suivez
particulièrement là encore on on on
l'identifie par exemple on a beaucoup
par des des commerces de téléphonie hein
ou d'un certain nombre type de commerce
qui sont deséé voilà bon qui sont des
machine àant rap restaurant rapide
restauration rapide voilà pour autant
euh objectivver euh et
démontrer j'ai pas de moi j'ai j'ai pas
de d'exemple en tête sur le
ressorteou à travailler avec les greves
des tribunaux de commerce ou un suivi un
peu plus fin est-ce que par exemple
quand les parquets sont représentés dans
les affaires de procédure Collectiv
est-ce que c'est quelque
chose une question sur laquelle vous
avez une attention particulière pour
l'instantou on peut dire
cela les kodaf permettent
aussi en terme de lutte contre les la
fraude de faire émerger un certain
nombre d'objectifs qui souvent nous
laissent à penser vous vous citiez un
certain nombre de commerces je pensais
aussi alors je pas stigmatiser mais les
kebabs aussi parfois parce queon a cette
notion d'injection rapide et de création
rapide avec finalement une traçabilité
qui paraît pas évidente qui mériterait
d'être vérifié donc on les vérifie enfin
on en a fait là trois récemment
précisément parce qu'il y avait cette
notion d'absence de traçabilité mais
sous l'aspect fraude donc avec un Codaf
et et derrière peut-être l'idée
effectivement d'embrayer sur une enquête
financière euh qui nous permettra alors
si elle révèle quelque chose peut-être
d'aller à la source des infractions qui
sont qui sont à la à la source de ces
revenus donc on prend effectivement le
problème complètement autrement par une
source d' d'information totalement autre
et je pense effectivement alors en effet
le commerce et puis et puis peut-être le
Codaf ou d'autres instances
d'information oui mais ceci dit il faut
pas toujours parce qu'on a des résultats
sur certains types de commerce comme ça
mais il faut pas nécessairement alors
bien sûr il y a le lien avec le tribunal
de commerce quand on y est présent
systématiquement ça permet d'identifier
des situations il y a les Codaf mais
parfois il est plus simple de travailler
et dans ce cas-là c'est ce qu'il faut
choisir sur des qualifications de droit
commun ça peut être du blanchiment pour
lequel on éétablit pas que c'est du
blanchiment de stupéfiant mais peu
importe du blanchiment de droit commun
ou du travail dissimulé
hein par dissimulation d'activité et et
et et peut-être que c'est du blanchiment
de stupéfiant mais que ce lien là on l'a
pas démontré mais pour autant si on
arrive à l'attaquer sous des
qualifications de droit commun autrre
c'est c'est efficace aussi pour le coup
voyez n nous retient c'est la question
de la
corruption la corruption des
services d'état corruption
pardon de petites minutes et puis après
on aura épuisé les
questions corruption dans les
administrations est-ce que vous avez été
confronté à des situations de cette
nature je pense à la maison d'arrêt vous
nous avez dit que vous avez une maison
d'arrêt importante de 700 c'est une
maison d'arrêt oui c son détenu
actuellement est-ce que cette vous avez
eu des cas est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire comment est-ce que vous pouvez
suivre ces questions là
particulièrement nous avons une affaire
particulièrement qui est qui est encore
en cours qui concerne des surveillant de
la maison d'arrêt je vous disais que
alors le centre pénitentiaire l'ensemble
du centre pénitentiaire c'est 700
détenus pas seulement la maison d'arrêt
mais c'est un un centre de détention
également alors je veux pas vous dire de
bêtises je je n'ai pas le chiffre exact
mais en tout état de cause il y a
effectivement des pénétrations
importantes de de stupéfiant et
régulière hein je vous disais le chiffre
il est constant les trois dernières
années c'est 12 kg au total beaucoup de
projections par drone mais aussi
beaucoup d'entrées au niveau des
parloires et c'est là où se pose la
question d'éventuelle complicité parfois
euh et il y a un dossier qui concerne
quatre quatre surveillants mis en cause
sur effectivement de la de la corruption
et de la complicité euh notamment pour
avoir faire entrer un certain nombre de
produits stupéfiants donc là ce sont des
enquêtes qui sont évidemment menées dans
le cadre de commission ratoire et et qui
sont en cours d'instruction qui
permettent alors avec un une bonne
coopération hein de la de la direction
de la du centre pénitenaire puisque y a
il y a un vrai échange sur les
politiques pénales à la fois euh la
compar immédiate systématique le
disciplinaire à côté et puis l'échange
d'information régulier des brouilleurs
aussi qui sont mis en place au niveau
des drones donc des des aussi des
dispositifs que le centre pénitentiaire
essaie de mettre en place et puis pour
nous une politique pénale très présente
puisqu'on a un service d'exécution des
peines dédié au traitement des
infractions en centre pénitentiaire donc
une seule affaire ces dernières années
alors quand je dis ces dernières années
moi j'ai un recul très récent mais en
tout cas de l'historique que j'ai pu
retracer qui est assez récente et qui
était assez significative puisque pour
le coup elle a véritablement facilité
l'entrée beaucoup aussi de parachutage
aux abords des des centres
pénitentiaires donc on a cette vraie
problématique de sécurisation euh des
lieux de détention avec des parfois des
des possibilités d'approcher d'assez
près finalement la la détention qui pose
question sur les dispositifs de sécurité
hein aux abords des maisons d'arrêt
puisqu'on a on a des mineurs qui
arrivent en scooter le le soir qui
tournent autour du centre pénitentiaire
et qui arrive à projeter tout simplement
en lançant par-dessus les les murs
d'enceinte donc c'est c'est quelque
chose qui interpelle en terme de
dispositif de de sécurité et puis qui
est assez fréquent on a énormément de
mineurs impliqués parce que évidemment
les les peines en couru sont assez assez
faible lorsque ils ont 14 ans 15 ans il
y a pas de détention au bout et ils sont
souvent utilisés euh pour effectuer ses
ses livraisons et ses projections et
puis le drone ces dernières années alors
qui est devenu vraiment le l'outil à la
mode je dirais qui fonctionne finalement
assez bien avec du parachutage de
produits stupéfiants en centre
pénitentiaire donc un vrai point
d'attention puisque pour nous un vrai
facteur de de risque et puis on voit que
les quantités qui circulent alors c'est
celles qui sont saisies donc il en
circule beaucoup plus que ce qui n'est
saisi mais c'est assez significatif
quand
même sur sur la corruption euh je pense
que c'est vraiment une thématique
centrale parce que si vous voulez euh
c'est un peu l'arlaisienne la corruption
c'est-à-dire que tout le monde en parle
mais des dossiers qui tiennent et qui
vont jusqu'à une condamation il y en a
peu alors ça tient à la difficulté aussi
de cette qualification parce qu'il faut
démontrer un Pact de corruption c'est
compliqué hein c'est pas simple mais je
pense que la corruption en lien avec le
trafic de stupéfiant c'est un point de
vigilance majeur nous on a eu plusieurs
enquêtes qui n'ont pas abouti aucune n'a
abouti une visant des un douanier une
une visant un agent pénitentiaire et une
enquête c'est plus périphérique mais
visant une fonctionnaire de police de la
Cross
64 ces enquêtes n'ont pas abouti par des
poursuites ou des
condamnations mais sont des indices et
et aujourd'hui on voit et mon expérience
passée m'a montré évidemment il y a des
milieux qu'on cible l'administration
pénitentiaire oui forcément les les FSI
aussi dans mon ancien ressort à Vienne
on a pour le coup poursuivi est condamné
lourdement une gendarme militaire de la
gendarmerie qu'on a pris en flagrant
deslit elle rentrait 30 téléphones à peu
près tous les mois bon donc les FSI oui
les élus locaux à ne pas négliger dans
le cadre de nos dispositifs partenariot
là aussi sur mon ancien ressort on a mis
en examen un élu qui dans le cadre d'un
JTD un groupement local traitement de la
délincance avait eu une information sur
une opération de police qui allait se
monter dans une cité et qui a divulgué
cette information pour pour voilà parce
que c'est une personnalité qui comptait
dans le quartier peut-être en terme
électoral aussi euh et et divulguer
cette information les agents des ports
sur lesquels nous travaillons
actuellement he et le ministère de la
Justice a créé à la fois une sur l'Arc
Atlantique et l'arc méditerranéen un
travail parce que dans les ports il y a
une telle différence juridique de statut
déjà si repéré en terme de maquis de qui
ça dépend qui a compéten les portes sont
évidemment des points de de potentielle
corruption importants les aéroports
secondaires et puis et puis je le dis en
toute honnêteté le ministère de la
Justice nous sommes nous dans une phase
vous le savez où nous recrutons beaucoup
d'agents contractuels beaucoup hein qui
travaillent dans nos bureaux d'ordre
penau à enregistrer les procédures à
euh nous avons peu de contrôle en terme
terme d'enquête de moralité de sur sur
le recrutement de ces agents
contractuels très peu hein et et et donc
il y a voilà tous ces pointsl mais après
l'objectivé et c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il y a un vrai travail à faire
sur la corruption si vous prenez le
nombre d'affaires de de condamnation lié
à des affaires de corruption en lien
avec le trafic de stupéfiants en France
par an je pense que ça en fait pas lourd
vous vous disiez je vais donner la
parole à mes collègues qui l'ont demandé
vous disez qu'il est difficile de
démontrer le le pacte de corruption et a
un sujet de texte d'évolution
législative
là je sais pas parce que
intrinsèquement je vois pas bien comment
on pourrait le modifier hein c'est
simplement une infraction qui est qui
est compliquée à caractériser parce
qu'elle est elle est très opaque qu'il
faut il faut démontrer c'est c'est c'est
pas simple hein c'est pas simple après
alors je je pense à des des des des
dossiers plus plus basiques hein mais
enfin la complicité par aide ou par
instigation et quelque chose qui peut
être plus facilement démontré je dirais
que parfois faut juste être pragmatique
et trouver effectivement le champ de
qualifications qui permettent qui
permettent de voilà en effet parfois on
a des qualifications qui sont
compliquées juridiquement à à qualifier
mais on peut partir sur d'autres champs
enfin nous c'était le choix qu'on a fait
procédural de partir plutôt sur de la de
la complicité à la fois par aide et puis
par par instigation en réalité merci
alors j'aiis vu euh marieur finera Orte
et Catherine Conconne qui souhaitait
poser des questions
oui merci Président c'est juste une
petite question bonjour à tous Voilà il
y a quelques années j'avais suivi une
affaire concernant un jeune militaire
guyanais puisque je suis sénatrice de la
guyan qui recevait des colis de cocaïne
en provenant de la Guyane donc je
voulais juste savoir est-ce qu'il y
avait eu d'autres cas
depuis je m'adresse à Monsieur le
Procureur de Bayonne puisque c'était
chez vous est-ce que vous avez
connaissance je sais pas parce que vous
vous con vous savez que chez nous c'est
il y a un phénomène de mules
qui malgré les contrôles à 100 % ben ça
change pas grand-chose puisque ça
continue et donc et quand j'ai su qu'il
y avait à Bayonne je me suis dit je sais
pas on arrivve à or rassi pour arriver
jusqu'à Bayon en plus bon c'est
certainement par voie postale puisque il
s'agissait d'un colis donc voilà je
voulais juste savoir est-ce que il y en
a eu il y a eu d'autres cas comme
celui-là et voilà je vais peut-être
passer la parole à Caroline Parisel mais
alors c'est vrai j'ai un de mes
magistrats honoraires qui était
procureur adjoint en Guyane c'est
effarant il me dis quel était le taux de
personnes chargé entre guillemets hein
par avion c'est absolument effarant bon
mais ce qu'il y a c'est des livraisons
par voie postale aussi oui qui que les
que que l'administration des douanes
essaie de tracer hein c'estàd qu'on fait
certaines procédures en traçant des
colis mais ça c'est quelque chose de
plus répandu Caroline vous avez
peut-être les douanes nous nous
informment qu'un colis euh contenant du
stupéfiant est en cours de livraison
mais en fait c'est livré dans des points
relais avec des fausses identités donc
on n'arrive pas à
remonter Catherine Conconne
oui merci bonjour donc Catherine con
sénatrice de Martinique l'autre
territoire qui fait partie à mon avis
des des plus affectés hein contte tenu
de nos de du gabarit de notre population
on est moins de 400000 et pourtant euh
les affaires de drogue sont extrêmement
répandus chez nous euh vous avez dit
avec regret tout à l'heure que les
enquêteurs ne disposaient pas de moyens
de téléphone et cetera pour pouvoir
tracer toutes ces communications euh ça
m'a l'air simple a priori à mettre en
place pourquoi ça se met pas en place
c'est quoi le problème euh est-ce c'est
une volonté est-ce un manque de moyens
euh comment vous expliquez
ça simple mais pas simple euh
c'est-à-dire que on on en revient aussi
au cadre juridique de ce qu'on appelle
nous les techniques spéciales d'enquête
voilà qui sont régis par le code de
procédure pénale
organisé et qui peut-être mériteraiit
d'évoluer mais l'équilibre est délicat
parce que évidemment il y a d'un côté la
défense de l'État de droit il y a ce que
nous impose la jurisprudence européenne
dont on pense ce qu'on veut hein que ce
soit un bien que ce soit un mal mais en
tout cas elle existe hein et et et c'est
une pression qui est forte et d'autrees
par les moyens dont disposeraient les
enquêteurs si vous proposez au service
de police d'envisager des solutions moi
mon chef de l'ofaste propose de créer ce
qu'il appelle un pack TSE un pack
technique spécial d'enquête balise
écoute vidéo sonorisation qui serait
autorisé par le juge des libertés et de
la détention mais euh don don le détail
de mise en place ne serait pas
communiqué notamment pas communiqué aux
avocats et c'est un dispositif qui est
prévu en Belgique exemple voilà
bonsier voilà dans lequel on place
toutes ces procédures qui sont
dérogatoires
exactement tout une question et là il
m'appartient pas de me positionner
là-dessus je m'en garderai bien mais
tout est question d'équilibre entre d'un
côté un état de droit et ensuite une
efficacité
mais ce dont il faut avoir conscience il
faut pas être naïf c'est que face à
toutes ces techniques modernes nous
sommes de moins en moins efficace voilà
ça c'est une
réalité je peux ajouter en tout cas sur
le terrain ce qui ressort des enquêteurs
et qui ont qui sont de moins en moins
motivés pour faire du judiciaire parce
que les règles sont de plus en plus
compliqués ils ont peur des nulités
c'est vraiment une responsabilité pour
eux c'est que quand on a une enquête
préliminaire en matière de stupéfiant
c'est très très lourd à gérer parce que
que c'est une demande de de
géolocalisation du téléphone ab initio
délivré par le parquet ensuite au bout
de 15 jours on doit aller voir le JLD
qui nous autorise une première fois puis
ensuite tous les mois on doit y
retourner et y compris pour les écoutes
téléphoniques où euh on a un délai
minimum enfin maximum de 2 mois d'écoute
téléphonique donc c'est très très lourd
à la fois pour les enquêteurs et pour le
parquet de gérer moi si j'avais pas
d'assistant autour de moi de juriste
assistant pour m'aider à gérer ce serait
impossible en fait parce que faire une
requête la transmettre la retransmettre
aux enquêteurs ça demande extrêmement
enfin beaucoup de temps et je dirais il
y a pas de par rapport à ce qui est
possible de faire pour le jugeinruction
il y a pas de de parallèle pour pour le
parquet je dis par là que ce qu'on
constate c'est qu'en matière de
stupéfiant on est efficace sur les les
réseaux locaux à partir du moment où on
arrive à être tréactif et à démanteler
rapidement le le le trafic avant qu'il
ne s'installe de de manière plus longue
sur nos territoires ruraux parce que là
encore on a une possibilité de
réactivité par rapport aux dénonciations
des des voisins et la la force qu'on a
c'est de pouvoir intervenir rapidement
et de démanteler rapidement et de juger
rapidement ces personneslà si on doit
passer par une instruction judiciaire
inévitablement on est parti sur un an et
demi d'enquête avant avant le jugement
les personnes vont être libérées et on
aura pas des peines à la hauteur de les
enfin oui ce sera une peine
proportionnée mais il y aura pas cette
réactivité qui est attendue par la
population qui est extrêmement
importante pour voilà arracher les
racines de manière rapide il faut pas
travailler tous les dossiers comme ça
mais en tout cas sur les les petits
réseaux locaux véritablement c'est
inefficacité c'est la rapidité et c'est
difficile à mettre en œuvre avec les les
moyens législatifs aujourd'hui ouvert au
parquet dans le cas de l'enquête
préliminaire au législateur oui pour
avoir plus en tout cas des délais plus
longs et un ouplissement des règles dans
le respect des libertés indiduelles j'en
parlis avec le juge des libertés la
détention qui est très réactif aussi ça
lui demande aussi beaucoup de de travail
et il disait mais pourquoi ne pas
imaginer une autorisation par personne
et puis ensuite on fait des
géolocalisations pas par objet en fait
parce que on a un téléphone une voiture
la voiture c'est la géolocalisation
c'est le téléphone c'est la gocalisation
l'écoute téléphonique donc ça ça fait
des demandes mais à rallonge on a des
dossiers comme ça uniquement
d'autorisation alors que le JLD c'est
très bien ce qui se passe il peut
autoriser pour la personne impliquée sur
tous les moyens possibles enfin voilà
c'est c'est une idéeitation par personne
et des délais plus longs sur la
reproduction voilà c'est ça hein la
suggestion oui l'idéal ça serait dans
dans le respect de l'État de droit monie
bien sûr de la séparation des pouvoirs
on l'a bien compris madame la procureure
si si je si je peux me permettre si je
pouvais ajouter encore un petit souhait
parce que je souscris à ce qu' vient de
dire mais d'être dit mais le souhait
aussi de la spécialisation et finalement
d'une
uniformité au niveau du territoire de la
formation et de la spécialisation des
OPJ euh je voudrais quand même citer ici
une réforme qui nous inquiète tous un
peu en tant que procureur alors on
attend de voir comment elle va être
portée mais cette réforme de la police
judiciaire euh qui tend à une nouvelle
centralisation euh des moyen et une
administration unique alors a sûrement
une vocation de rationalisation ceci dit
quand on étudie la carte et et je l'ai
étudié avec soin et je me suis rendue à
Lyon au contact de la des zpj au niveau
zonal pour voir un petit peu où se
situait l'in euh le territoire de l'in
680000 personnes aucune antenne police
judiciaire dédié alors aujourd'hui som
toute quand je fais le constat et avec
le nouveau directeur départemental la
police nationale on fait le constat
notre police judiciaire à bourcambrress
pour l'ensemble du territoire qui est un
territoire extrêmement vaste c'est
quatre OPJ c'est la même chose qu'avant
c'est-à-dire que le maillage territorial
réforme de la PJ qui est passé par là
change strictement rien nous sommes en
zone grise et d'ailleurs la carte qu'on
m'a présenté était très significative il
y avait les zones qui était couverte par
la PJ qui avait des directions
interrégionalesou zonales aujourd'hui de
police judiciaire donc formé spécialisé
disposant des techniques d'enquête et
disposant de l'information puisque on a
des antennes au fast avec des gens qui
sont spécialisés pour les trafics de
stupéfiants et à côté de ça on a des
territoires laissés pour compte parce
que moi je le vis un petit peu comme ça
où il y a une zone grise elle est en
gris sur la carte et elle n'est pas
couverte euh donc elle est couverte par
la gendarmerie certes et aujourd'hui par
des émanations des sections de recherche
mais en terme de PJ d'OF d'office
central et finalement de maillage
territorial on est sur des des zones qui
finalement n'ont pas de police
judiciaire alors moi j'attends de voir
encore une fois je je veux être
optimiste et peut-être que la réforme va
nous amener une centralisation de la
formation et de la spécialisation mais
en l'état c'est ce constat là euh qui
qui fait quand même que sur des
territoires extrêmement vastes on a zéro
PJ donc la technicité dont on parle
autant vous dire qu'elle n'existe pas
très très
clairement merci Madame madame Paulie
gagin demande la parole oui merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur madame monsieur le le
procureur chers collègues je voulais
savoir si vous estimez que le
renseignement territorial joue un rôle
suffisant en fait pour vous aider en
amont du
travail que vous conduisez
ou si là encore on est dans une
situation un peu indigente qui
nécessiterait des moyens supplémentaires
et puis ensuite j'ai quand même le
sentiment en vous écoutant que on a un
problème systémique c'està dire qu'on
ira toujours moins vite
et on est très siloté par rapport à la
menace et les moyens de des malfras
qu'on a en
face vous parliez monsieur le Président
des petites coupures mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est les cryptoonnaaies
en fait en plus donc la
traçabilité ça va devenir un autre enjeu
dans le domaine du numérique par lequel
plus de la moitié de la criminalité et
et du narcotrafic passe donc si on
change pas d'approche non plus je craint
que on soit
toujours en retard sur sur l'histoire
qui est en train de se faire et cette
histoire là est plutôt morbide donc il
faut il faut peut-être qu'on se dote de
à la fois de de conceptions différentes
et de moyens plus
adaptés alors c'est le propre de la
police et la justice d'être à la traain
du délinquant dans dans dans l'histoire
mais c'est évidemment quand les choses
s'accélèrent il faut courir encore plus
vite sur la
cryptoonnaie évidemment c'est un enjeu
majeur mais la cryptoonnaie elle est
traçable
elle elle est traçable et donc je je
pense pas qu'elle supprimera le cash
elle ça sera un vecteur de plus en plus
important pour les réseaux criminels
c'est certain mais mais je pense que le
numéraire restera quand même quelque
chose d'important voilà sur votre
question sur le renseignement c'est un
peu une question piège euh enfin c'est
pas une question piège mais c'est alors
la police judiciaire développe c'est
évidemment ses propres capacités de
renseignement hein la la police
judiciaire est un service de
renseignement judiciaire donc elle
développe ses prês sur le renseignement
territorial comme sur la sécurité
intérieure hein la la la
DGSI tout
dépend des relations il y a pas de
relation institutionnelle formalisé
entre les procureurs de la République et
les services de renseignement bon on a
souvent à choper sur la classification
du renseignement aujourd'hui les
procureurs de la République en tout cas
lorsqu'il le souhaite sont habilités bon
c'est mon cas mais ça s'est fait dans le
cadre du lecteur de la lutte contre la
radicalisation et le terrorisme des
jedes où on a finalement noué des liens
avec les services de renseignement
territoriaux qu'on naait pas du tout
avant voilà mais les renseignements
territoriaux ne nous alimentent quand
même pas spontanément en renseignement
sur ce type d'affaire alors après ils
alimentent leur propres services les
services de police ou les services de
gendarmerie en tout cas ils sont censés
le faire mais la vision qu'and on les
parquets est très parcellaire très
parcellaire c'est ça m'est difficile je
sais pas toi moi ça m'est difficile de
savoir ce que le renseignement
territorial sur le le trafic de drogue
remonte au service de police ou de
gendarmerie j'en ai pas une vision
précise moi je dirais même plus court je
je n'en ai aucune en revanche
c'est-à-dire que nous n'avons pas de
contact direct et pas de retour sur la
source et sur la façon dont information
et est remonté en interne au service de
police les procureurs n'en n'en sont
absolument pas euh destinataires du tout
hein donc il y a pas de lien
institutionnalisé donc nous n'avons pas
de visibilité en revanche là où la
culture a changer c'est dans le cadre
effectivement de la lutte contre la
radicalisation et dans le cadre des des
jeed lorsque nous sommes en réunion euh
d'état-major donc en en périmètre
restreint là pour le coup moi je vois
une nette évolution ces dernières années
d'informations croisé à l'occasion de la
problématique radicalisation mais qui
souvent recouvre d'autres réalités hein
et par exemple les stupéfiants sont
aussi quelque chose qui émerge dans dans
ces instances là lorsqu'on étudie un
individu en particulier sur lequel on a
une problématique radicalisation on va
étudier l'ensemble finalement du du du
spectre bah de son de son train de vie
de la façon dont il se comporte de ses
activités et là l'échange d'information
je trouve ces dernières derr années a
beaucoup progressé dans le sens où nous
sommes maintenant destinataire des
informations parfois en amont des GED
parfois au cours des GED nous avons
accès aux notes blanches et à une
information détaillée et donc il y a je
dirais que queil y a il y a des
barrières qui se sont rompus là à
l'occasion de la lutte contre la
radicalisation donc dans ces instances
on échange de l'information mais elle
n'est pas destinée aux stupéfiants et en
revanche dans le casre de la lutte
contre les stupéfiants les les RT pour
nous nont n'ont n'ont pas de contact
direct avec les par ok très bien merci
là comme l'ARE vous nous avez parlé de
frontalier les rapports très brièvement
avec vos voisin espagnol et Suisse vous
en êtes satisfait sur ces sujets de
stupéfiant
alors sont des éléments d'ailleurs je
vous communiquerai dans la réponse au
questionnaire on a on a fait en octobre
un colloque financé par la mildk sur la
lutte contre le narcotrafic
franco-espagnol qui était intéressant
qui était assez riche d'enseignement
pour être très étiique
euh c'est avec l'Espagne il y a une
coopération qui évidemment est forte sur
cette thématique là mais il y a toujours
des pierres d'achopement les pierres
d'achopppement et ça elles sont pas
propres à l'Espagne c'est souvent la
méconnaissance de nos cadres juridiques
distincts parce qu'il restent distinct
et du coup la mauvaise utilisation des
voies de communication ou de ce qu'on
peut obtenir ou ne peut pas obtenir par
exemple si on comprend pas qu'en Espagne
le et je dirais que mais je je prêche
PRODOMO ça valorise beaucoup le parquet
à la française en Espagne le procureur
de la République doit passer par un juge
pour presque tout ce qui rallonge
beaucoup de délais ce qui ajoute
beaucoup d'aléas si vous voulez faire
une perquisition en Espagne si vous
voulez faire une perquisition chez
quelqu'un dont vous n'identifiez pas que
c'est le domicile du mise en cause vous
n'aurez jamais gain de cause vous
pourrez pas faire une perquisition ce
qui chez nous est possible donc il y a
cette différence de jur régime juridique
qui est importante ensuite il y a une
part d'intuitu personné qui est
importante et ensuite mais ça c'est
propres relations internationale il y a
une part de réciprocité qui est
importante c'est-à-dire que pour avoir
de la réciprocité il faut intéresser sur
et parfois les thématiques que qui
focalise un état sont pas forcément les
mêmes bon en Espagne on l' on l'a connu
euh quand la France s'est engagé dans la
lutte contre le TA ben l'Espagne a
davantage coopéré sur la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants voilà donc tous
ces élémentsl évidemment sont à prendre
en
considération côté Suisse alors mon mon
étonnement mais encore une fois je je
suis au stade encore du rapport
d'étonnement he puisque je suis dans les
6 mois de de la prise de fonction
c'était découvrir que nous n'avions
effectivement émis aucune demande
d'entraide en matière de stupéfiant et
en matière d'ailleurs de de de
délinquence organisé de façon générale
ces trois dernières années euh en
revanche nous sommes destinataires et
pour traiter moi-même le le champ de
l'entraide pénale internationale nous
sommes destinatairees de multiples
demandes dans des domaines très variés
des autorités suisses qui sont très
proactive sur le champ de l'entraide
alors principalement sur des infractions
de droit commun du routier mais aussi
des vols et aussi des atteintes au
personne donc les Suisses sont sont sont
extrêmement demandeurs on exécute nous
très très facilement ces demandes
d'entraide et je me suis rapproché tout
récemment du du procureur général de
Genève et donc de de mon homologue la la
première procureur de Genève pour
déterminer avec elle justement les
champs dans lesquels on pourrait
favoriser une entrée directe parce que
moi je pense que l'entrée judiciaire
c'est avant tout effectivement une
question de de de relation proche de
proximité identifier des objectifs
communs et aller effectivement sur nous
de notre côté plus de proactivité
faut-il encore une fois que sur ce
payjex du du frontalier émergent les
affaires qui le qui le permettent donc
ça c'est un un constat euh une
difficulté des services d'enquête qui
nous sont remontés et et à l'occasion de
de ma visite du CCPD de Genève une
difficulté sur la poursuite
transfrontalière avec les autorités
suisses qui se passe pas toujours dans
dans les meilleures conditions avec des
des des freins assez importants des
Suisses lorsqu'on est sur de la
poursuite transfrontalière donc ça se
fait quasiment peu puisqu'il faut qu'il
y ait une atteinte grave aux personnes
ou une menace avérée dans le casadre des
accords de de Paris et qu'ils ont une
vision très restrictive donc par exemple
l'infraction de droit commun qui donne
lieu à une poursuite expose les les
enquêteurs en cas de difficulté ou en
cas d'usage des armes par exemple à des
poursuites et donc qui sont extrêmement
restrictifs extrêmement craintif sur
cette poursuite transfrontalière
appelant de leur vœux une une évolution
là des des accords de de Paris et du
texte et puis peut-être la pratique
aussi des des Suisses alors qui eux
viennent assez facilement franchissent
la fron assz assez facilement et avec
effectivement une interprétation parfois
compliquée donc un risque lorsqueil y a
ce franchissement de frontière qui en
tout cas m retranscrit par les par les
enquêteurs et puis sur le plan de
l'entraide effectivement une entraide
directe à à
nourrir merci beaucoup on vous remercie
pour votre contribution orale
aujourd'hui dans l'audition puis on
compte sur vos contributions écrites
pour compléter tout ce que vous n'avez
pas pu dire et puis vous revient des
choses on est preneur
petite précision très courte mais je le
mettrai un note sur les outils parce que
vous parlez des outils juridiques moi il
y a un point sur lequel je voudrais
insister mais qui relèvera peut-être
plus des Girs mais je ne comprends pas
pourquoi l'importation de stupéfiants
bande organisé relève de la Cour
d'Assise spéciale et pas le meurtre en
band organisé je pense que dans le cadre
des règlements de compte et leur
explosion c'est un vrai sujet voilà et
que sur la politique d'usage de
stupéfiant alors c'est peut-être quelque
chose de personnel mais je pense qu' il
faut aussi qu'on assume peut-être à
nouveau un discours plus répressif sur
l'usage de stupéfiant qu'on l'a fait
jusqu'à maintenant parce que on a quand
même les politiques de santé publique et
de prévention sont pas toujours très
pertinentes et à cet égard moi je pens
tout simplement aussi à la possibilité
de saisir sur l'usage de stupéfiant là
je passe à nos jeunes publics mais je
pense que on leur saisirait
systématiquement leur téléphone portable
je pense que ça serait une mesure qui
serait plus utile que l'amand voilà bon
c'est une suggestion bien noté merci
beaucoup bon retour dans vos
juridictions